[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we're asking the question
how was London how was it and then we're
answering that question because as of
the recording of this we are still
pretty fresh off of our trip to London
England United Kingdom Europe were for
long I yeah I still have jetlag I still
AM
well are you waking up I'm waking it is
late hours the react lot of us I'm
waking up like 3:00 a.m. I'm like ready
to go and then I'm like don't you gotta
go by to sleep well the thing that I'm
noticing is at about 7 o'clock at night
it hits you I get hit really hard with
this like irritability that like I was
out to dinner with the family and they
were all talking and you know
interacting with one another which I
mean that if that's your thing yeah it's
a family's talk it was not my thing at a
time I mean I stopped at one point I was
like guys I just want to tell you we're
like halfway through the meal I'm so
irritable right I just feel like I could
explode with irritability and I'm just
like very testy you know this is kind of
crazy because you know how it's
manifested itself with me extreme
restless legs a dream restless leg now I
have restless legs syndrome and ah I I
think I talked about this before but
anyway it's this you know the the
irresistible urge to move and what was
happening is it was in my right leg
well started getting in my right hand
hold on this is only when you're
sleeping right no it happens when you it
happens typically when you're trying to
go to sleep but what was happening which
was so weird is that because of the
jetlag
it was hitting me about 7:30 for me so
on Monday night I was in my therapy
appointment and I started
having it real bad in like my leg was
bouncing up and down and then my I've
never had it in my arm and so my arm was
also like I was like moving around a lot
and my therapist was like you're very
uncomfortable with what we're talking
about right now aren't you and I was
like well I mean yeah but it's because I
got restless legs bra in my arm and that
restless leg in your arm and then why
not call it restless arm and then I
don't know if what that is and then the
next night I went back to my therapist
with my wife it's a long story
well go into it and we just needed an
emergency session and it was actually
great incredible session but during that
it happened again and I was just
thinking about it
just show me exactly what you were doing
like you see my foot okay your foot you
you say you're just waggling your foot
but what about your arm you okay you got
a fist you got one hand in a fist and
you're like grabbing it with your other
just moving just look very uncomfortable
yeah I look like I'm squirming my way
out of something and maybe I was yeah
like when you get sent to the
principal's office but you have to wait
outside and everyone's walking by going
to lunch and they see you sitting there
yeah and you're like his legs twitching
is his he's holding the hands with
himself but just to be clear cuz a lot
of people think oh I tapped my leg a lot
I must have that's not restless leg
syndrome so if you have a tendency to
let out excess energy by like bobbing
your your knee up and down like that not
restless legs not the same thing
restless legs is this you only can
explain it if you have it is this
irresistible urge to move to the point
that you feel like you're going to it's
get so uncomfortable not to move so it's
not like the little thing we use bobbing
up and down and well you know I wish it
on your worst enemy I'm sorry you have
that rep okay go ahead though I don't
have it yeah never experienced it I mean
I'm only I'm only imagining what it
would be like just by hearing you
describe it right and I'd describe it in
such a vivid way you don't even need to
watch the video version of this podcast
in order to get all the course maybe you
do because I did I did a lot a lot of
physical things
pretty impressive well you shook your
foot and that wasn't even in a shot but
you saw it they can see your face
looking at me yeah
they can't why are you yawning man see
it's hitting you jet lag dude I'm from
London once island and once I told them
I was about to explode with irritability
then it actually helped and I didn't for
the record yeah she separated herself
from it
you are not your emotions but um they
seem to not have heard me it wasn't like
they were spine it's like oh thanks for
sharing they could have said that yeah
they just kept talking but it made me
feel good to acknowledge that I had
feelings instead of letting those
feelings control me
yeah that's what I'm actually trying to
do and it's it was nice to know that it
was jet lag and that I'm not just a a
jerk that doesn't want to be around my
family because I do yeah because I
thought something was going I thought
something was wrong with me it was so
intense and it was just that no no you
would be asleep right now and you're not
yeah yeah because 7 7 p.m. feels like
let's see Plus 8:15 a.m. which is 3:00
a.m. there is no 15 a.m. 1,500 hours
would be 3:00 p.m.
right there's no 15 a.m. it's just
that's the next day you know we should
change that
did you just keep counting they should
count from the beginning of time so
we're gonna be done at what time it is
we've never been in London so this
podcast is gonna be us sharing with you
our first ever experience in London
except for being at the airport I mean
we've been in we've connected through
the London Airport but we've never been
in the land of London like out and about
yeah so we're gonna share those things
with you we were there for VidCon and
also for a concert that we played which
was at the same venue but was
technically well it was it was a part of
VidCon but it was a separate event
separate ticket it's a little
complicated but it doesn't matter cuz
it's over and I was just looking at the
pictures from the concert and I was like
man that crazy pictures really validates
having done it when you have
cool-looking pictures of it
where we got some pictures taken by it
was a Annique as I yeah Thank You Niq
Niq mythical beasts doing that from
Amsterdam came over and took some
pictures of us she took a lot of
pictures and and then she sent us what
she deemed to be the cool ones and they
are very cool I was posted one to my
Instagram so lots of thoughts about
London we'll get into all that but first
I just wanted to share a story with you
something that happened to me that I
haven't shared when I got back from
London so a few days ago I injured
myself no surprise and I just thought I
wish I would share with you
loyal your biscuit listener and to you
Rhett loyal friend and irritable
companion yep so I get home and I happen
to mention to Christie I was like I got
a I'm gonna put my passport away I'm
gonna put it back in the safe I I keep
my passport in our fireproof safe which
ultimately I just think if there was a
fire we would I guess we'd grab the safe
but if we didn't maybe it would survive
but I don't know it's like cuz fireproof
man it's fireproof I agree that's true I
wouldn't grab it is heavy it's a lot of
things as I'll get into and she was like
oh get my passport too because I haven't
put mine back and I was like well we
need to keep him in there yeah yeah so
I'll go get hers and the safe is not in
the place that it used to be well don't
tell us where it's at because I'll break
in and get it I have to tell you okay
because what's more important is me
telling this story then keeping secret
where my secret safe is I got a dummy
safe I got a safe that they'll take and
they think that they got the safe where
is that one I'm not gonna tell you
where's the real safe definitely not
telling you that oh you didn't fall for
it this time but you had already told me
that it's under your bed am I say you
can't fit into my bed bro you got a big
safe yeah like how big is your dummy
safe you I've seen your dummy safe it's
like you walk in the front door it is
quite there and could carry but the real
safe I can get into what I've never told
you about it
me safe is in in the front of your house
just sitting there like somebody will a
thief walks in you're like don't be safe
here lie says says he says take me I'm
dummy I'm not a dummy safe this is free
you have a walk-in safe I might let's
talk about you getting hurt
ironically a walking safe is not safe
because you can get locked in well I'm
not planning on locking myself into my
safe is pretty small it's like the size
of for Trapper Keeper stacked on top of
each other it's got a lid on it anyway
it's not in the place that it used to be
and neither is Jade's dog kennel Jade is
here with me today
Jade say hello Jade say hello I'm
telling a story about you to your kennel
your cage I don't like to call it a cage
because it's her home when we're not at
home and she likes it it makes him feel
secure to go in there and more
importantly she doesn't pee or poop in
it
oh so you so you you still put her in
her crate well yeah because because she
will pee and poop in the house she's got
she part dotson and that she's got she's
the part that likes to sneak in pee
anyway when Britain moved into our house
we converted the office into his bedroom
right glorified closet anyway that's
where we kept her kennel and where I
also kept the safe and I kept the
printer so then I'm like I got to find a
new place to put our printer I moved all
of that stuff that's in that bigger room
that he now sleeps in into the closet
that's underneath the stairs that lead
up to my bedroom so like picture like a
Harry Potter kind of closet you open the
door to that closet there's a like why
don't just put Britain in there I
thought about it I didn't think about it
I was like hey if it's good enough for
Harry yeah give him something write a
song about have you been in this closet
you opened the door you hit a light so I
didn't know it was there
it's a bit next time I'm going in though
when you open the door you're looking
down the staircase that like it goes if
you look straight ahead once you open
the door
it goes away from you too it slopes down
to a point so you're not looking at it
sideways where it's sloped and sideways
you're at the tallest point and then
it's sloping down to the floor when you
open the door when you open the door and
a matter of fact it kind of slopes down
and then there's like a cubby hole with
that I put to stop yawning while I'm
telling a story
it's boring then I know you're
jet-lagged but it's not good for my ego
story's boring so it slopes down and
you're done by the architecture of this
under the stairs it's room this is
important the architecture is important
to what happened okay so you need to be
able to visualize this it's like you
walk in it's by six feet tall it
immediately slopes down to about two and
a half feet tall where there's a cubby
hole that I put the printer in oh that's
nice then in front of the printer
I put the safe in front of the printer
it's just a small safe for Trapper
Keepers then to the right there's
there's enough room for a bookshelf that
has all of our board games that we use
to keep in Britain's room Oh board game
and then so you can walk in and get to
the printer or the safe or the board but
the board games in the safe huh yeah I
don't have a walk-in safe
I really value I could make this whole
closet as safe I got all my board games
in my water
chutes and ladders is very flammable
vintage addition the this it will be
easy to get to the printer and to the
safe except for the fact that then at
the last minute I realized I didn't know
where to put Jade's crate so then I put
it in right smack dab in the middle and
it fills basically the whole floor of
the closet so when I go in there to put
the two passports that are in my hand
into the safe you got to move the crate
but moving the crate is difficult
because there's almost the width of the
door so I move the crate to print yeah
well this is not sustained no what what
you can do is you can basically I can
stand in front of the crate and bend
over like hinge then put my hand on the
crate or somewhere and then kind of
reach and grab what I printed that's
worked a few times easy but the printer
is a foot higher than the safe
I didn't I didn't take that into account
this was gonna be more difficult so I
I'm standing there my shins against the
front of Jade's crate
then I hinge over and I realize I can't
reach the safe so what I do is I take my
hand and I extend it out as far as I can
and when the slope goes down it it then
goes vertical for a 2x4 and then goes
horizontal into the cubby hole where the
printer is so there's a little 2x4
height where it rested your hand I've
rested my hand on that and I like I'm
pushing hard holding up my bodyweight
with my right hand and then I'm reaching
down with my left hand to open the open
the safe and I realize well I can't open
the safe with my left hand because I got
my left hand doesn't know the
combination only my right head flows
there's no combination am i safe it's
just for fire it's not for theft all you
got to do is push grab the handle push
down on the safe grip coming here no
squeeze the handle and then it will open
my mind scans my eye before I walk again
I don't care that's not true I mean so
then I'm like I got a switch hands so
then I got to get my right hand down
there because the safe handles on the
right side and so I put my left hand up
there and I take my right hand down so
now I'm always maintaining a point of
contact so now I am my my whole upper
body weight is being held up with my
left hand and then I reached down again
I have the passports in my hand but then
with my other three fingers I'm gonna
grab the handle push down on the safe
pick it up all the way open the lid and
then I'm going to throw the things in
and then I'm gonna close the lid and
then I'm gonna I'm gonna unhinge myself
and I'm gonna get out of there like a
proud man that's not how it happened
so I'm holding myself up with my left
hand and I reached down to grab the open
the safe and I open the safe and as the
lid is coming up and I'm trying to pull
the lid up my left hand slides yeah all
for the 2x4 that's holding my whole
entire body weight up into the cubby
yeah and it goes in the air and then I
just I start falling so the lid is up on
the safe my hand is in a freefall my
body begins to be in a freefall forward
and the lid my right hand starts to fall
too and I try to catch myself with my
right hand because it's I let go of the
safe and I turn my hand around to put my
palm toward the ground and catch myself
but as I do that the lid of the safe
comes down on my fingertips I think I
see the finger that got the brunt of it
and then the lid snaps shut on my
fingertips while my left hand comes down
on top of the safe and pushes my entire
body weight on top of the site fled
there by smashing completely my middle
finger and I'm not just seeing the tip
I'm saying just bull it clamped down
just below the base of the fingernail so
basically the whole top part above that
knuckle was safe from fire yes it was
that is the positive spin on this sword
the negative spin was that I was in
excruciating pain where I had say me
worthy dirts I had locked my middle
finger it long right hand into the safe
and was applying my full body weight on
top of it and I was in like a yoga
position that you just can't magically
hinge up you just can't magically like
my feet are way back here behind of the
kennel the fire safe position doing fire
safe I was like bent over a barrel
basically and I don't know at that point
I'm like struggling to get my finger out
of the safe and it won't come out I'm
like I wasn't
alone I was not saying English I was not
saying expletives I was grunting like a
caveman in pain agony and just total
despair that I was in then I was gonna
be there forever but how soon after that
kind of thing happens like in the middle
of it are you thinking I'm gonna talk
about this one of your biscuits because
it hurt that's what happens out back
that's what happens to me now anything
that happens that is like I shouldn't
got myself into this situation well I'll
answer that because yeah what happened
was it was an excruciating amount of
pain and of course time slows down at
that point but somehow I was able to hop
my left hand off of the safe onto the
floor and then ripped my right hand out
of the safe it was still closed though
it didn't fully latch that would have
been impossible and then I like put both
my hands on the dog crate and like peel
myself back so that you could out of
trouble there too putting all your
weight on a dog yeah then slaps the
whole thing and then I don't know if I
immediately lay down on the floor or did
a dance around the room but I looked at
the footage and you can hear because I
have that I have that security camera in
that room and now and but I was out of
frame but I played it back and I could
hear the noise I made it was like
[Music]
[Music]
and named and then I was like oh did you
say you saved that clip oh I got the
clip yeah wha if it works we'll throw it
in there and I'm like wallowing on the
ground like uh-huh and like Christie
comes in there she's like what's wrong
she told me later she thought that I had
fallen down the stairs it's like the
noise is your reaction are falling down
must have fallen down the stairs no let
me explain what I did it'll take 12
minutes I would have been going except I
was laughing and I was thinking about
how ridiculous this was and that I was
going to share it with you on air
biscuits at that point she got me some
frozen peas and she was like what
happened to you and I was like I smushed
my finger in the safe I can't tell you
the details because I feel kind of faint
right now and I was thinking about what
had happened and I was starting to feel
faint and I'd sat there on my butt with
frozen peas on my finger for like ten
minutes before I could like feel like I
could stand up you thought you might
have broken maybe well I was convinced
that like I had lost my fingertip or at
least the nail and I still may lose the
nail oh man it hurts it still hurts a
little bit but um I am so appreciative
of nails you know what's kind of
interesting as well it wasn't for
fingernails yeah I would have lost the
fingertip I think that's it's a protect
it's an art it's armor I'm not gonna
tell the story because I've already
because it's not much of a story but you
know the finger that I hurt before we
left for London
about something about putting my hand
into my guitar case and the thing going
between my fingernail oh yeah it's the
same finger the
middle finger of the right hand it's
been swollen you see that it's missing
this is a sign he's been swollen ever
since it's like I was worried that some
about the cart the qutilat the critical
on the right side of your yeah this
thing went and it bled it went down in
there and then bled I did that one time
and it got infected that's what I
thought was happening it swelled up so
big that I superheated a needle
underneath a flame and I stuck it in to
like drain all the pus out I thought
it's gonna get some sort of like London
bacteria you know like you know like
some old-world bacteria that was gonna
take me out how bacteria works okay
we're both fine though my well I'm not
fine my fingertips still hurts okay we
are going to talk about London but first
we are going to talk about link shirt
he has wow the brand new a Palka lips
collection shirt well it's a whole
collection there's a whole story behind
this this this collection this is
something that you that we're doing
we're we're doing a collection of
clothing story waist story where it's a
always don't want to wear stuff there's
logos you want to wear something that
tells a story so there's a story I by
the time you're hearing this I'm sure
that the trailer for the story is gonna
be out in fact I just recorded the video
for it so for the hopefully it's out and
this is going to be something that we're
gonna try we're trying it and seeing how
this goes but we have this awesome an
artist who kind of created all this
incredible stuff that fits this theme
about a post-apocalyptic world in which
dogs have kind of taken over and I'm
Paul
Colette humans are the pets and it's
really cool stuff that just says
mythical on it I'm very excited about
the pants we have some camo sweats camos
very comfortable so wrap all that at
mythical dot store check it out we also
have an Amazon store where we got stuff
over there so
repure boys okay let's talk about London
like we said we had never been to London
the thing that I'm really into are the
little differences I thought maybe we
could start with just a couple of the
the little differences that we noticed
well there's the thing that you talked
about at the beginning of our concert
that you were fascinated with when you
stopped at a traffic light and it's
because the lights red that that also
means in London that you need to stop
even though you're driving or riding on
the other side of the road when you see
a red light you should stop but once
you're stopped when it's time to go the
light just doesn't turn green people it
turns yellow to warn you to give you a
heads up that it's about to turn green
and then it turns green so it turns
yellow on both sides of a red warning
you're about to stop yellow red and then
heads up you're about to get to go again
yellow green and I I've never heard of
this I did I just no I just thought this
would be something that they say about
London this seems important I think it's
that way in other places too
nothing just London but but no the place
has never seen it I don't deny that it
could have a reason there's not other
places and it's not it's unnecessary I
love it it's unnecessary I love it but I
like I'm a planner man I like to know
when something's gonna happen and
specifically when it comes to driving I
like to I like to be the guy who takes
my foot off the brake yep and I like a
little gas so here's why it's
unnecessary because it's it flashes for
such a short period of time less than a
second your action that you take after
you see the yellow is the same action
that we here in America take when we see
green but here's the psychologically
there's no difference though there's no
active difference there's this there's
definitely a psychological difference
because it's if the lights green and I'm
not going I feel like a failure so I
feel like I have no chance of being a
success unless I start going risking
going when it's red which is which is
unsafe and a violation
I'm like I know I'm not looking for
emotional support from the way I respond
to the trick give me an opportunity to
feel like a success when driving and I
like it because I want to be in motion
but do you think that when they made the
decision is greatness in Parliament or
wherever they made the decision they
were like we were yelling about we want
people to feel like success no they
think they have a traffic reason for why
this is the case there's no other way
engineer what do you think it is like
walk a mile in their shoes the reason
that you from an engineering standpoint
and I haven't thought about this much so
I could definitely be wrong let me just
state that so I am open to hearing the
engineering argument for this but the
reason that can we Kim and can we leave
part where you say look I could
definitely be wrong but well who they
can loop it if they want I'm just
inviting them to loop so the reason that
the yellow light is on is in between the
green and the red is because there's a
lot of variables happen there's so many
variables while all the cars are moving
sure where you're at how fast you're
going so there's there's a decision to
be made right there is no decision it's
a binary decision that needs to be made
because like when you're slow you're
slowing out how fast am I gonna slow
down am I gonna go through the light am
I not there's only one decision that you
can make when the light turns green and
that is to accelerate to go and so by
seeing the yellow light for a split
second the the outcome is the same it's
unnecessary it's not needed it doesn't
do anything because people are
responding to it the same way that we
respond to a green light the thing that
I read about it was that it's related to
stick shifts because if you're not to
get in the right gear but what it's just
another heads up because you get you
have to there's preparatory work I'm not
making this up this is something that I
happen to read I understand that and
there's a lot many more manual cars in
England than there are and I only drive
manual but here's my thing that's a lie
but I'm but I do like if we're all I get
I guess okay all right so we don't we
don't need to camp out it's not up there
long enough because that's not a bad
read
because if you because now there's a
variable if you've got half of the
people in line have manuals and half of
the people have all automatics the
people who have automatics are
theoretically going to be able to start
that much sooner so therefore maybe the
length of the yellow light is the
average time that it takes for someone
to get into the right gear and go to get
in first gear and go now I would also
say that you could also already be in
first gear like we do in America wait so
I did I mean the reason why I like it is
is a is a reason already gave it's
emotional its psychological so I don't
there's no argument here
it's fascination only well one of the
thing that I pointed out at the
beginning of the concert as well is that
the urinals there's a few differences in
the bathroom we'll talk about but one of
the differences in the bathrooms and the
men's bathrooms is that the urinals and
I'm assuming that's what they call them
as well on the wall that you pee into
you can't poop into a my high I haven't
an emergency I think they call them loo
holes the bathrooms called a loose no
where anywhere was there a divider
between the urinals and and now that it
is not exclusive it's not that there's
only dividers in the US but there's
dividers in most places at least 50%
yeah well I did not encounter one urinal
divider and they're pretty close to each
other so it's kind of like it's now I
don't necessarily have a problem with it
but you know I don't feel I don't feel
completely comfortable you know what I
think it is they don't talk they don't
have small talk with strangers that's
something that doesn't happen like it it
happens some in America like people who
strike up a conversation with somebody
just out and about do you think that's
the case you just went to one city for a
couple of days I read about this oh I've
been reading
I just wanted to validate what I thought
were the difference is I'm like I just
happen to find that out like they don't
they don't have small talk on like the
tube you know you know it's weird for
them
to speak to each other strangers now in
New York IIIi mean on the subway I I
didn't I don't see people talking to
each other but I think maybe there's a
higher likelihood that Americans will
shoot the breeze at adjacent urinals if
there's no divider but the Brits don't
have to worry about it I've had a number
of people strike up a conversation with
me while I was urinating in London no no
definitely no London but I but if there
was a divider not my preferred
communication now like I don't even talk
to I don't need to turn my head I would
will not respond itself I don't talk to
myself at a urinal no definitely you
know you don't want to be at a urinal
muttering to yourself that's not a good
look so they don't have dividers they
also don't have paper towels that's good
on them and this is I mean this was the
area in Amsterdam as well I think and in
Australia there may be anything
everybody else has figured out that we
don't need to dry our hands on trees
except for us but is it really better
for the environment because you're using
electricity which in most places is
still the majority of the electricity is
being produced by fossil fuel-burning so
I mean I guess once we go all renewable
it definitely makes sense it has been
proven that they're less they're not a
sanitary though I think don't quote me
on that I think that they did a study
that the the hand dryers even though
sometimes they say it's more sanitary
it's not more sanitary because it's
blowing bathroom air around you know
it's in bathroom bathroom areas little
pieces of pee and poop man well the
thing and they a lot of them have that
Dyson where you'd like it's that small
slot that you got to like totally get
you flat hands in and then everybody up
a little bit on air blade and then you
like slowly pulling your hands back out
but it's it's nerve-racking man because
you feel like you're so close to the
plastic parts that everybody's been so
close and not only that what happens on
the way out
I'll touch that you touch the handle you
don't have a paper towel you can't do
the perfect bathroom trip without it
without a paper towel we wrote a whole
song about this
[Music]
while the doorknob may be tainted and
the exit make it on the wall into the
trash can
the paper towel for opening the door we
we still use that instrumental at the
end of our ear biscuits we do perfect
bathroom trip is the is the outro Wow
that's right so you can't have a perfect
bathroom trip in England because you're
going to end up contaminating yourself
on that your door handle no matter how
well it goes think you can use your
shirt sleeve or your own hankie or your
foot but you open it up with your foot
now everybody who decides to open it up
with their hand has been compromised did
you feel like the hotel was different
definitely and we stayed at the hotel
that was right there at the venue at the
excel mhm and so I've stayed at this
brand of hotel in the US unless I'm
about to sound like a spoiled brat fine
whatever I think we already do deal with
it we are spoiled we sound like it all
the time but keep it rolling while we're
talking about differences I'm gonna tell
you I mean the sheets were rough man the
sheet she's a rough the sheets felt like
a little bit like a little cardboard E
and then the TP in the bathroom I was
gonna the team Jenna if she thought the
sheets were rough but like she works for
us she's nice you know she she she puts
up with us all the time she can probably
put up with her some rough she did you
think the sheets were rough yeah because
they were not ice I didn't notice I
didn't notice the sheets are rough but
I'll tell you what I noticed when I took
a shower and then I got that towel down
and I was I was drying off I dropped my
face first and I take a deep breath and
the freaking towel smelled like ramen oh
yeah they they make towels out of ramen
there
I mean it's if it got real damn it might
would have just turned into a floppy
noodle but maybe that might be an
isolated thing because I have a theory
about
the rough toilet paper and the rough
sheets again I stayed at this Brent this
kind of hotel in the US and I do not
remember this and again I'm not saying
that it was intolerable I slept fine
isn't it
it's just good the sheets that I enjoy
on my bed and at the typical hotels that
I frequent in the United States of
America have very soft sheets it's just
part of the deal
high thread count and also they have
quilted toilet paper inside of the
bathrooms
I have quilted toilet paper in my
bathroom so what's the theory because I
have a you know I I want to treat my my
butthole well I mean that's I mean
that's what I do that's the kind of guy
that I am I actually have a bidet but
then you know I got a bidet I got a
bidet for days I just think I just think
that something about okay like I can set
the exact temperature of it you you have
the history we're so pampered you have
the history of the the English people
like you know I could see er my own
butthole with the temperature of my
bidet if I wanted to
well do you don't do that that's not
good that's not caring just like you
want it you just want to when you're
done you just want that thing you want
to hear the theory the theory is that
Western Europe like people they like
there it's a rough it's a rough bunch
man
I mean actually look like legitimately
if you ever if you ever if you ever read
Guns Germs and Steel which I have
recommended on this podcast before a lot
of people ask why is it that the people
from Western Europe who went to the New
World
why why did they not die from the
disease's why was it the Native
Americans that died from the diseases
that the white people brought because
they had rough rectums that's why the
reason is is because they had lived in
close quarters and sort of this like
uncomfortable bacteria-laden lifestyle
sewage on the edge bring people on top
of each other life you go back to like
old school Western Europe back in the
Middle Ages it was dirty as crate
so crazy unapologetically stepping on
chicken people dying all over the place
and then you've got you know people in
the New World the Native Americans might
open space wide open pottery they
weren't living on top of each other and
so you got these super viruses super
bacteria that are coming across you know
on these boats and then just decimating
the native population I think that they
just have this ruddy they've been just
been rough man they and they like it
rough
they like the sheets rough they don't
know that the sheets are rough but
something about coming over to we're
soft coming over here and like starting
a new nation that's all about freedom
you know it's like we just got we got
ahead of ourselves you know we're like
oh you know what we can't wait we can't
vote we don't have to have a king we can
have a president and we got all we all
got hot we got all high and mighty about
all our freedoms in the next thing you
know we I want a wife my every thought
with a blanket right we wanted
everything so soft and we got it and now
we're spoiled
oh we're spoiled and and and and they're
like no no keep it rough man and so I
actually I envy them I envy them that
they can take your rush they can take it
rough they can take a rough sheet they
could take a rough TP because my booties
adjusted it's like now go over there and
I can't take it is that gonna have to
travel with my own freakin toilet paper
cuz I'm just uh you know spoiled
American yeah you you spending too much
time minding the wrong gap you feel me I
never saw that sign by the way I never
saw a sign that said mind the gap I saw
science said underground but they call
it the tube
yeah we went all that I think an
underground is it is though as a
pedestrian tunnel while we're
complaining about I know a subway is a
pedestrian tunnel well we're gonna say I
loved I loved London okay let me let me
just say that but let's go back to
complaining now that said it that's
where I'm going to land okay I loved
London I plan to go back but let me
complete think it's funny to complain
let me
I'm just gonna complain a little bit
more cuz I do want to talk about the
food I feel I have to talk about the
food
okay now let me just say I know that
again not only are we spoiled as a just
as a culture we are spoiled a above and
beyond because we live in Los Angeles
any food we just we have access we got
we can get some good food y'all we like
I go back I go back to North Carolina
and I in and and it's kind of a whole
lot better than it was even when we
moved away but if you don't give it up
if you don't get up in there in the
Raleigh area you don't you're not gonna
get real good food but now no you're
gonna get comfort food that's
comfortable everywhere reliably good I
mean I don't enjoy Golden Corral is what
I'm saying is that I just can't do it in
I know and you know I you can judge me
all you want I just can't enjoy it
anymore
because I've gotten I gotten too big for
my britches and but what happens is is I
I we go to London and we just well you
know what I'll let you take it from here
because you had you had some choice
opinions as well why don't you tell them
about well they there's the you know
it's the trope that the foods not good
in London and then they said but it's
gotten a lot better and what you know
women what it was like well we went to
this place we we had to grab some lunch
and we're like gonna split we end up
going to this place called Slug and
Lettuce listen it's a in the chain we
bow why on earth we bout to throw Slug
and Lettuce under the under the bus
we're about to rip a bubble decker bus
we're about to rip him a new one with
the roughest toilet paper you have ever
ever felt on your rectum why on earth
would you name a place Slug and Lettuce
maybe it means something different in
English and why on earth what I suggest
after we saw like you guys class is that
well because they had a win you out
front and it said they had fishing tips
on the minutes like you know we need to
eat like a British some food from
Britain well and let me eat some fish
and chips
we need to premise this with the fact
that we weren't really in the main part
of London like where the excel is I
don't know what part of London we were
in but we're like 40 minutes out we're
never suburb we were in the Anaheim of
London for those of you who are familiar
with the Los Angeles area like if you go
to Anaheim and you're like I don't like
LA well you haven't been to LA like
that's it's different right it's a
suburb so where the excel is is not
exactly London well and we took a
gondola across across the the landfill
to in the river timpz yeah to see to go
into Oh to where they had all these
different places where you could eat and
we're like perusing the menus as you
walk down the pathway I'm like let's
just eat here we're gonna grab and go
something it's like I got fish and chips
and they got salads if you don't want
that and I need to eat some fish and
chips but the reason we didn't eat at
there was also like a Mexican place it
was a Mexican place it was an Italian
place but listen we have to tell a side
story before we tell the Slug and
Lettuce story because the reason we
didn't get the Mexican food is because
the night before we had been out in the
main part of London like we went to
shortage and then we ended up going to
Soho or somewhere I don't know where we
went anyway so we were kind of going we
were bar hopping basically going to
these old english bars that said things
like since 1529 which would say that was
amazing to go into a bars that were that
old we into this really really cool
place that was inside an old prison and
the well old jail they had old jail yeah
you go downstairs and it was all but
this brickwork and they seated us in
this room that was an archway entrance
that then it was one huge table that had
bench seating the other left side on the
right side in the back just like a used
seating and the whole ceiling was like a
brick tin hanger it was like art and
arch was an old so yeah it was the old
jail cell and we didn't realize it and
we were like very cool
we we're hungry we're getting some pints
but we wanted some food as well and so I
was like uh are you guys serving any
food cause it was late it was like
almost midnight it was like you guys
serving me food he says yes we have what
do you what do you call them the small
Mexican crisps and we all looked at each
other and you said it's like tortillas
he's like yes what really is tortilla
chips and some salsa so and then you
were like oh yes that so he said I'll
say I'll bring you everything that I
have he had some olives he had some
pickles he had again this is very cool
place gherkins but he brought the
Mexican crisps the tortilla chips now
again we're from Los Angeles we know
what a freaking tortilla chip is we
probably can get some of the best in the
world right we're very close to the
place where there's less source Mexico
and the the tortilla chips were I mean
they were tortilla chips yeah they
weren't absolutely horrible they were
small Mexican crisps the salsa was
ketchup with tomato onions in it it was
ketchup with onions in it I mean that's
the only way that I can describe it he
was ketchup with onions in it now I I
ate two bowls of it because I was very
hungry you ate and I like ketchup and
onions yeah it's just that's not salsa I
know but I mean you're in London why
you're ordering chips and salsa it's all
they had so that's why the next it
wasn't like we chose that it was like
that's all that they right right
everything they had which I was still
having an incredible time I loved
everybody I loved the scenery drinks huh
the drinks were great the atmosphere was
great that the the people were good
Bourget but then the next day you
realize I want to get some tradition I
want to get some fish and chips and I
was like well I definitely I wanna go to
the Mexican restaurant cuz I'm not in
the mood for Mexican crisps this is
Valentine's Day I was kind of I was in a
sad place at that moment you know I just
seemed I wanted to be with my wife I
didn't want to be with you right eating
Mexican crisps at some arena it was an
arena
it was it was an arena sluggin but you
insisted on some lettuce at least well
they got fish and chips and it looks
British in there and Jenna picks out the
menu and she's like crinkle Broud and
she's like well there's like 18 pages of
drinks and there's like one page of food
it's like well there's just a bar there
was a lot of stuff on them there was a
lot of stuff on the menu because at that
point I had already made the decision
that I wanted to get something healthy
mama gonna fish and chips regardless of
how bad it is so I had a little issue
because I wanted the salmon and the
superfood salad right oh gosh but they
had salmon with vegetables and then they
had the superfood salad with this other
meat and so I went up there to order the
bar I was like so yeah I want the
superfood salad but instead of the
instead of this the steak I want the
salmon he's like oh we gotta do that it
was like I had asks to like walk out
with something and he was like we can't
do that I was like you sure you can't
just like you can't just do the salmon
you might as well it was said you know
I'd like to burn this place down yeah
yeah and then he went I'll go ask my
manager he goes and ask the manager and
I see him ask the manager and the
manager like looks at me he's like like
what like what what okay so can't
substitute maybe I've gotten spoiled
because you can substitute other meats
in it now at that point you know you
weren't you weren't that spoil because
at that point what did you do I ordered
both I said okay well now I think your
salmon with that I'll take this ha the
superfood side the salad whatever give
me both of them the fish and chips just
to cut to the chase here were horrible I
mean why calm the fish and chips are
horrible they were to do with it would
the blandest tasteless I mean I'm
sitting there like pouring vinegar and
salt over the whole thing I mean I need
a lot of salt and they don't they don't
salt a lot of stuff I guess well no
because it was because we had good food
but at the Slug and Lettuce we might as
well have had a slug or lettuce after
our show we're devoting this whole
freakin podcast to complain it about
everything in London
we'll be back guys horrible after the
show we're like we can't go in it we're
just going to go back to the room we're
gonna order room service and we're like
we find out like the whole
tell doesn't have room service at this
time of night yeah that's so wait we're
at the front desk and they're like well
can we order pizza and he's like yes and
he like gives us three different like
Flyers of where you can order pizza no
nope no places that are no chains that
did I recognize didn't know we'd know I
mean listen I it didn't like I think
that Domino's and Little Caesars etc
Pizza Hut is like the best pizza in the
world I think we've but it's good pizza
I mean it's passable Pizza I will say
that we have come to appreciate it
enough because they delivered this pizza
it was so bad my wife loves pizza I had
to put her on video chat in order to
show her mmm how sad this pizza was and
it's a place it's a pizza delivery plane
let me tell you that the guys at the
front desk at this hotel we were staying
in specifically pointed out this place
they were like we got that the other
night and it was great and so I was like
okay so I think that that that it's us
you know I I it was awful I don't
understand listen Pizza is simple it's
dough it's sauce is cheese and it's
toppings and they you know I failed on
what pizzas but they failed miserably in
all four categories it was uncanny I was
like how much of it did you eat five
pieces but I did not enjoy it you didn't
enjoy a woman bit at all it was just
sustenance I was freaking tired after
our show in the meet-and-greet we I mean
we hadn t eaten anything in a very long
time oh we were we're so sad it was 2:00
a.m. but let's talk about the food that
we did enjoy because I also had what I
considered to be one of the top
it's definitely top 20 meals yeah I've
had interests I'll agree with that if
you want to get really good British food
get Indian food we ate in this place de
Shoom in shortage and people this is
like a sit-down
straat fancy cocktail drinks like all
the Indian food that you would expect
from an Indian restaurant and so it's
like a sit-down meal dining experience
people are lined up around the block
waiting for like hours like people
probably wait in three hours waiting to
wait waiting to then put their name in
and wait we waited an hour and a half
and we just had to have one person there
and it it was worth it was worth it it
was so good it was like a magical
experience and I think that's the key
you eat all this stuff and it's just so
bland or like unbelievably horrible and
then you'd like this have that you go to
these dining experiences and they but I
think it's top 20 is either really great
or just really great by comparison but
but it was fabulous but can you explain
it was so good how okay so right okay
traditional English food has a
reputation for being bland right sort of
meat and potatoes mushy peas but then
one of the culture you know one of the
countries that they imperialize has
incredible food and they end up getting
they end up getting that food and now
they kind of call it their own yeah but
if they like that food they didn't mess
it up because Indian but why didn't it
make the other food better right Indian
food is so flavorful and so bright in
like it's some I think it may be the
best food on the planet I think it might
be my favorite like flavor I mean we
were gushing about it for hours but it
did because okay
because the other good meal we had was
the night before when we went to that
that really old bar that I think was
founded in 1666 which I thought was cool
oh yeah we had some meat pies they were
good and we had a Guinness and I had a
venison meat pie that was oh and then we
got like a little sampler they had like
a scotch egg and some other things all
great really really really good you go
to the right place you can get some
goods and that's like traditional stuff
it was really good it was like it just
had the right flavor balance because
Steve
Stevie got a meat pie at Slug and
Lettuce remember that thing look like oh
gosh they should just call it slug on
lettuce and that's what they should
serve you know you're going you're like
I'll you know what I want cuz it's all
what you serve
I want a slug on a piece of lettuce then
you know what you will have a better
experience than we had this episode of
your biscuits is not brought to you by
Slug and Lettuce we also had some great
Thai food
very interesting Thai food just
catty-corner - - oome when we couldn't
get in the first called the smoking goat
we're gonna talk about anything else cuz
I let's switch from the food in the you
know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so anyway
we we had some good food we had some bad
food
we took a walking tour I like to take a
walking tour when I'm new to a city I've
said this before mm-hm
we took a walking tour this one well it
happened to be a Jack the Ripper walking
tour yeah turns out didn't know much
about the guy he's a serial killer and
so I probably already knew that and I
think I did but I just didn't want to
dwell on it
so I found myself walking around the
city and it is but cold and windy as all
get-out and I'm like we're a little
underdressed too a little underdressed
and this woman is walking around saying
oh look here a woman was disemboweled
and her and her you know she her throat
was slit and in her her her innards were
were thrown over her shoulders and let's
walk over here I got another story for
you
this woman's uterus was was cut out this
woman her throat was slit and her
innards were thrown over a thrown out of
her body
hey no let's keep walking I got a nut
surprise here here's where a woman yet
you'll never believe this
a woman's throat was slit and her
innards were were thrown out yeah that's
what Jack's keep walking and I think
that just kept happening
it was headed colder and colder it was
like it was it was like a cereal walking
tour it was like the same walking tour
again and again and again and
the whole the cuz the theme of the night
was we don't know who Jack the Ripper
was but it might have been this guy it
might have been this guy it might have
been this guy and at the end she was
like so who do you think it was and we
were like I think wherever he is he's
probably warmer than me right now I was
just thinking does it matter
I mean does it really matter what we're
gonna go put him in jail we are horrible
walking to her patrons because like no I
was being very not ghost tour in New
Orleans like we were we were not good
patrons there no but because that that
girl that was not good she was not doing
a good job but this woman was was really
good at her job she was a ripper or
ologist virologist that's just that's a
title you can just give yourself that's
also someone who uses UK toilet paper
[Laughter]
VidCon was a blast and what I mean by
that was we did it we did a Q&A Stevie
asked us some questions submitted by
mythical beasts who were there I always
have fun doing that because we I the
objective is to throw Stevie off of her
game we're like just try to and you know
bring the audience along for the ride
that was fun we did a meet-and-greet we
got a press the flesh with some fans
that's a political term for just like
shake hands with people yeah you should
come up with a new one and we had we had
done our concert which I'm gonna watch
the tape back I'm sure I'll have a lot
of notes for us but in general I had a
really fun time I said it from stage I
was proud of you you sat there and you
played your keyboard for the first time
did you okay look it's speaking of that
now I've already told you that our you
know musical hero John Mayer is learning
you told me that he was learning to play
the piano and I went on his Instagram
and saw that he was doing that do you
know who else is learning to play the
piano right now and I just saw in his
Instagram John Legend he's he's been
finger syncing this entire time nope
Jimmy Fallon Jimmy Fallon is learning to
play the piano and very musically if it
was like I am learning to play the piano
and he's taking a course an online
course that Harry Connick jr. teaches
really and John Mayer commented on
Jimmy's post and said I've got adult
onset piano fever as well and I was like
well hold on so do i and like John Mayer
was born five days after me I love him
and Jimmy was is a little bit older than
us I like him a lot too um now John
Mayer
commented on Jimmy's post I coming on
Jimmy's post at this point in time he's
responded to John Mayer okay as a
responded to me but you know I mean give
him time but what is it you want me to
get in the minute is there something is
there something in the air is there
something in the water is this Twitter
or Instagram
this is Instagram I'm on that shout out
to link Lamont on Instagram I'll get in
the mix it's just interesting that old
old men are teaching themselves how to
play the piano it's a it's a midlife
crisis kind of thing definitely seems
like it we had a great time at the
concert thank you it was fun for all you
who came it did it did open things up to
play that piano I want to make an
observation about the crowd at VidCon
not the crowd in the crowd but the the
other youtubers right not our people not
mythical beasts you're talking about
I've talked I think I know where you're
going I'm talking specifically and I
didn't know I didn't know mini I didn't
know any I you know I've got like the
British youtubers you know
TomSka and Jack and Dean and Dan and
Phil and you know the people who've been
around for a really long time that
everybody knows about I regret we didn't
get to talk to Jack or Dean I spoke I
spoke to Jack okay briefly
he said hello to me he didn't but now I
feel bad cuz you get to talk to him so
just back you know he said hello just
take it to someone probably but I
noticed that now there's the old school
like sketch guys that I kind of know and
understand but then there's like the new
school British vlogger right and I'm a
maybe they're just maybe they're
European in general maybe I don't know
but I just noticed there was like a
uniform you know I'm something there's a
lot of brow threading I noticed that
well yeah well but yeah both both the
men and the women are pay a lot of
attention to their eyebrows being very
perfectly shaped but everyone's an
athletic wear yes like school matching
sweats like all the girls have these
like they look like they're about to go
to the gym you're like a really nice
resort and they have their hair in
ponytails
they have a crap ton of makeup oh
goodness yes a crap ton of scent perfume
on yeah and they look like they're about
to run like a celebrity track meet you
know that you know that filter on
Instagram that like makes your face look
really fake and makeup II yeah they just
do that in real life
yeah but it's like everybody's really
well put together like an airbrushed
face and then the guys are the same sort
of the same thing going on but like an
athletic wear I mean look I got a hoodie
on you know I I'm ready to be athletic
at any drop of its ariana grande type
thing I think like you know with the
ponytail and the athletic wear she you
know she'll do that is that also I don't
he's not happening in this country as
well it's not just something that I'm
yeah yeah I don't observe the young
people anymore I just look over them you
look through your own kids right I have
noticed that like our kids are like
doing the athletic wear thing but I mean
it's a but but they take it to another
level and it's like
it's like if your backup dancers were
all wearing athletic wear you know it's
like it's like that it's a heightened
type thing tightened yeah and then you
get you're on an elevator and then it's
the doors are closing all of a sudden
the elevators open back up and all these
people pour in and they're like they're
very excited about themselves
oh well that's how I video okay yeah I
just felt like I was on an elevator with
a bunch of people very excited about
themselves now we're different we just
we're just very picky and demanding and
crotchety and and can fill I mean reams
of I'm audio with with complaint I'm not
complaining about the extremely you know
they seem happier less well-made and
athletic aligns happier than us but I
just made an observation I felt like I
was like I had fast forwarded to some in
the distant future we will colonize Mars
and everyone will wear matching athletic
wear the lure and paint their faces and
pull their hair really tight so that
they can be transported by the special
train that grabs you by your hair I I
don't you know I'm saying it's like that
would begin to make sense to me I but
it's so everybody looked the same they
uh it was very uniform was like this is
our uniform we are British vloggers
again I probably not a British thing you
think it's just it's just people of that
aid yeah on the internet yes yes yes
okay we are people on the internet now I
love the humor like let's not forget
that like we made a video with Tom's car
and in the middle of video I was like I
just I just love the way you funny you
know I didn't say that cuz that don't
even make sense but you know what I mean
yeah like that was my sentiment I really
enjoy your humor it's the greatest
what's the grudges it's the greatest man
it's the greatest humour so
self-deprecating so and we made it back
oh did I meet JJ Abrams on the plane
perhaps I mean I won't go into it but
we're buds
Revis and you know I'm I pointed him out
when we were at like waiting to get on
the plane we were like sitting there
yeah pre-flight like sitting in the
airport and then we start walking to our
seats just finished filming is that it's
not just JJ Abrams I mean JJ Abrams this
guy is responsible for the revival of
the Star Trek universe Star Wars Star
Wars the show like shows that we're on
our list he's a brilliant of our most
influential television television alias
it's a brilliant entertainer writer
director producer oh gosh this dude and
your seat was right next to him and I'm
like I made up my mind I wanna go talk
to him I just wanted I respected him so
much that he didn't want to do me too
well but it was a it was a 10-hour
flight and you weren't exactly and you
were next to him but I look at what was
on his phone throughout the entire
flight yeah he played word was words for
friends he played some other game I
couldn't identify he was texting people
somebody was like hey can you talk and I
was like why am i reading his text
that's wrong and I didn't read the rest
but it was kind of my face like I wasn't
like craning like he would hold up he
was kind of leaned back and he would
hold his I don't even near side or
something he wasn't wearing his glasses
he would hold his phone at like full
length full arms later so - so you could
read his text so that we could both read
his fault it was like link he hadn't
talked to me I'm and then that you talk
to him at the end over the course of the
flight I was like having this internal
dialogue about this dialogue and also
more importantly the dialogue that I was
gonna have with my daughter
if I told Lily that I sat next to JJ
Abrams and I did not speak to him she
would be very angry
yeah matter of fact when I got home and
I was like Lily guess who I met and like
we had a little yes or no game and
she guessed JJ and she got tears in her
eyes like literally she was like so like
just emotional about the fact that I met
him haha and so then I was validated
that like I had made up my mind like
when we're getting the bags and like
he's about to walk out and I noticed
that like a flight attendant not gonna
call him a stewardess came up to him
like halfway through the flight and was
like this is from another area - playing
it like crouched down and talked to him
for a while and like he was most
gracious
super nice guy anyway and so I was like
I was like JJ congratulations on
wrapping the chute and he looked at me
like dude am I supposed to know you and
I'm like I just saw the pictures online
that that were posted and he was like
thanks man thanks and he was like yeah
I'm I'm I'm just I'm really excited
about it I was like well you're not the
only one he was like yeah yeah I'm just
glad at this point that like I was
afraid at this point that you always
afraid at this point meaning when you're
done shooting but haven't edited it you
haven't gotten in that stage like you're
not gonna have everything's like we got
all of it and like so he gave me an
assurance early oka he had everything he
needed
JJ Abrams has got his he's got what
stuff on locked and he got what he
needed it's good to know and I was like
you know what I'm sure you do JJ and
that was pretty much it I'm sorry I had
to cut off my conversation with you in
order to turn and talk to him but yeah I
was kind of in the middle of our
conversation I just like whip pan I
understood okay I thought I was glad you
initiated with him I was glad you waited
until that moment to initiate with him
as well yeah because if he had done
something to embarrass yourself early
into the flight then it would have been
very awkward for the rest of the time
right for both of us because you were
next to me very gracious very gracious
dude very talented
okay well there it is so that that's
London I you know I'm sure that you have
your opinions about our opinions and you
know that's what the world's all about
that's what
that's about you know what let me know
hashtag ear biscuits because I am going
back to London on vacation with Lily and
I am later in the year both of us will
be back we are gonna go back team and we
are gonna experience it for just as
tourists no not in work mode and I'm
gonna I'm gonna tread lightly when it
comes to the food but I'm a tread heavy
when it comes to the experience I love
it I love it just got to make the right
choices that's all he's gotta make the
right choices
no pizza let me drop a recommendation we
got to start teasing that we do
recommendations at the top so that
people will endure our complaints into
the end so they can get at this point
and experience what I'm about to
recommend to you okay and to them so
because it's my week for a
recommendation check baby check baby 1 2
3 4 wrecks in effect is the name of the
band this is a reckon effect okay this
is another song that I was having a
conversation with Britain the other
night about Ronnie Milsap smoky mountain
rain keeps on falling yeah big fan oh
he's great
he's blind too it's just he's that if
you're curious he's the he's the blind
country music guy I think he was legally
blind I don't think he was completely
blind well he wears the sunglasses if
you're trying to picture who he is when
I dressed up like Lionel Richie and
saying endless love with you dressed up
as Diana Ross I looked like Ronnie
Milsap yeah you did
so that's who this guy is we were
talking about him talking about how much
we loved him and he was like well we've
talked about his voice and he was like
well have you have have you heard his
duet with Kenny Rogers no I was like no
I haven't because Kenny has a signature
voice he's like well and then we put it
on and I played it 1987's make no
mistake she's mine hmm sounds like the
girl is mine Paul McCartney Michael
Jackson kind of situation it exactly is
that about the same year a couple of
years earlier this was originally
barbra streisand kim carnes song but
then when they did their country version
they changed it from make no mistake
he's mine - she's mine and they want a
Grammy for it
incidentally it was also performed in a
season of Glee this song so you have to
listen to it on your own I'm not gonna
play it for rights issues but make no
mistake she's mine Ronnie Milsap and
Kenny Rogers I sat there and listened to
it I I'm getting goosebumps just telling
you a balance look at that and you
listen to it and you tell me who has the
better voice that that's the question
and it's almost an impossible question
they both you think well I would say
Ronnie Milsap just is based on but then
when I heard it Kenny Kenny starts and
he's got that rasp and it's basically
perfection and then when Ronnie comes in
as smooth like yeah it's a good mix I
can imagine I can't believe I never
heard this song you were going you're
gonna love it man and you might like it
too it's you might it it's the voices
the iconic country music voices in one
song I'll leave it at that
if they play Ronnie Milsap at the Slug
and Lettuce I might go back do you know
just have a drink and listen to some
music yeah yeah I take it all back Slug
and Lettuce hashtag ear biscuits let us
know what you think about all this
thanks for hanging out with us for
listening to us and whatever you're
doing in your day man I'm glad we're a
part of it yeah
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best